what we've seen in the past few days has
no precedent
the government has lost control of the
British economy
and for what
they've crashed the pound
and for what
higher interest rates higher inflation
higher borrowing and for what
not for you not for working people for
tax cuts for the richest one percent in
our society
don't forget
don't forgive
the only way to stop this is with a
labor government
and our problems don't end there raw
sewage in our rivers and seas backlogs
everywhere but our borders in our courts
in our hospitals crimes like burglary
totally unpunished
people told to drive themselves to
hospital after a heart attack
and millions of families pensioners the
poorest in our society still facing the
coldest winter of their lives
I said on Sunday that A fitting tribute
to the late Queen would be to turn our
collar up and face the storm
and we will
because Britain never won its battles
with wishful thinking
our success comes first and foremost
from the hard work The graft and the
common sense of the British people
a common sense that teachers up and down
the country drum into their pupils
fail to prepare and you prepare to fail
conference that's how the tours have
governed our our country for 12 long
years
that's why our economy has been more
brittle than others in the face of
crisis
they used to lecture us about fixing the
roof when the Sun was shining
but take a look around Britain
they haven't just failed to fix the roof
they've ripped out the foundations
smashed Through the Windows and now
they've blown the doors off for good
measure
conference
my government will be different we will
run towards the challenges of tomorrow
we will get us out of this endless cycle
of crisis
and we will do it with a fresh start a
new set of priorities and a new way of
governing
but it won't be easy
and the first step must be to tackle the
cost of living crisis
now the Prime Minister has finally
accepted there's no alternative to
Labor's plan to freeze Energy prices
when she was arguing against handouts
labor provided the clarity our nation
needed
we said this winter not a penny more on
anyone's bills
but politics about choices
and the choice the political choice
is who pays
working people or the oil and gas
companies making huge profits from
higher prices
the head of BP has said that this crisis
is a cash machine for his company but
that's a cash machine fed by working
people
so our choice the only choice the labor
choice is to put those profits to work
this party is always on the side of
working people in times of crisis
and